it's like a cat they'll just walk all  over you and not give any shits why is  that moving where are they in here  open the door open this door right here  what are you eating  Cheers how do you hold this what's up  we got like fifty Shades of Grey  happening here hello friend if I knew  one as a baby and we were best friends  so I could see this being a pet for me I  feel like a serial killer hey everybody  want to come see something cute rats I  misunderstood now these two are sleeping  on top of each other do you like being  under a but I feel like a pirate with a  parrot on my shoulder wait its tail oh  I'm done how come these are different  from sewer rats now I know that you're  just little perfect babies do I look  good tour does it look good tour I'm  like weirdly okay with this we're best  friends now see what's it doing it's  going in my shirt Cleo I swear - I have  in my hair right now  what get it there  I got it yeah you get it it's here